two months before he died Finley Bowden
appeared a normal happy baby
a month later still a seemingly
contented child enough to satisfy a
family court it had just returned Finley
to his parents care with the support of
Derbyshire social workers
but later photographs showed the squalor
of the family's life
and the reality of Finley's neglect
his father Stephen Bowden and his mother
Shannon Marsden were convicted of his
Savage and brutal murder on Christmas
Day 2020
as a parent you have no greater
responsibility than to a child who is in
your care
but Bowden and Marsden could not even
bring themselves to take off him into
hospital when it was
totally clear that he was critically ill
they've never given a reasonable
explanation as to why they did not do
this but it appears abundantly clear
that their primary concern was their own
freedom not the life of Findlay the
family photographs hid Finley's injuries
57 fractures 71 bruises and two Burns
probably from a cigarette lighter any of
us have been following this trial will
be
um you know won't understand how this
would how this happened really and the
child safeguarding practice review into
Finley's death must leave no stone
unturned in establishing exactly what
took place why these decisions were made
and what could have been done
differently if anything by local
agencies
this was Christmas Eve the last time
Finley was seen alive the next day he
was dead
official contact with his family during
his short life is being investigated
Martin brunt Sky News